un message on ne peut plus clair ce
matin là au nord de toulouse les
visiteurs semblent être au rendez vous
dans ce parc animalier d'attraction
[Musique]
la file d'attenté s'allonge sur le
parking ces familles attendent non pas
pour la billetterie mais bien pour le
contrôle du passé ni té nous nous avions
décidé de pernod nos vaccins à deux
doses
donc on a juste décidé ce matin de venir
ici et comme on a le passé on se pose
pas de question alors j'ai fait un test
car je prends l'avion vendredi pour
partir à nice
et comme je devais faire ce stage j'en
profite pour pour venir au parque pour y
amener mes filles qui m'ont réclamé
devenir opa dont concentre noah on
concentre nos activités sur 48 heures
mais avant de pouvoir s'enthousiasmer
les amateurs de sensations fortes sont
obligés de passer l'épreuve du
laboratoire depuis le 21 juillet
l'entrée dans un parc d'attractions
watts m est soumis à la présentation
d'un justificatif d'une vaccination
complète ou celui d'un test négatif de
-2 48 heures pcr ou antigénique une
règle qui concerne uniquement les
adultes et qui peut créer parfois des
tensions
je vais parler dans le grand détail
parce que son ex zaïre est vraiment
dmailer très très très très douloureux à
lire parce que c'était on parlait de
collabo on parlait de fachos donc
c'était des termes assez assez fort pour
juste voilà nous on applique juste là
les directives val mental se passa ni
terre qui nous il me faut embaucher
trois personnes supplémentaires pour
faire le contrôle des accès et des
passagers d'air et j'étais même embauché
un deuxième
surveillant un vigile nouveaux visuels
pour pouvoir avoir atténué tous les
problèmes qui pourraient arriver une
initiative pour éviter des situations de
conflits qui pourraient se produire
devant des enfants à l'image d'un
directeur de park près de metz agressé
verbalement et physiquement il y à
presque deux semaines par un client dont
le pal sanitaires n'étaient pas valides
des patrons ainsi en colère délaissé
devant à 50% de leurs visiteurs voire
jusqu'à 70% selon l'un des principaux
syndicats des parcs en france moins de
visiteurs et donc moins de personnel ces
derniers obligé toutefois de travailler
un peu plus avec un nettoyage
systématique des attractions à cette
baisse de fréquentation c'est que ben on
a dû faire des choix au niveau de
l'entreprise c'est à dire que nous avons
remis donc les pauses de midi pour les
attractions alors qu'on avait abandonné
cette idée l'année dernière pour ne plus
arrêter de l'attraction donc on a dû
rajouter donc ses attractions ces pauses
de midi et ensuite nous avons une grosse
décision c'est à dire que nous allons
nous fermons le parc plutôt on ferme à
18 heures et de 19 heures justement pour
baisser cette masse salariale est chéri
héros tient à souligner la résilience
des français face à des mesures pas
toujours facile comme le port du masque
il reste obligatoire dans le parc est en
pleine attractions